malestar e indignación generalizada ha
provocado los hechos de violencia
vividos este sábado durante un partido
de fútbol de la liga mexicana corría el
minuto 60 del partido de atlas de
jalisco contra los gallos blancos del
querétaro en la casa de éstos el estadio
corregidora cuando un pleito entre los
integrantes de las barras se salió de
control al grado de que los asistentes
al estadio incluidos padres de familia
con sus hijos pequeños tuvieron que
correr hacia la cancha del estadio para
tratar de escapar de la golpiza que ya
era generalizada estos hechos de
violencia dejaron han dejado varios
heridos algunos de ellos de gravedad y
el gobernador del estado de querétaro
suspendió la gira por europa que estaba
a punto de comenzar para indicar que las
investigaciones llegan a fondo y se
castigue a los responsables los
directivos de la liga mx han suspendido
todos los partidos de este domingo
correspondientes a la fecha 9 derivado
pues de estos hechos delictivos que se
han vivido en el estadio corregidora
algunos twitteros han incluso hecho
circular los rostros las imágenes de los
rostros de algunos de los que participan
en estos hechos de violencia que fueron
de una brutalidad tal que han generado
insisto la indignación de la sociedad y
la exigencia de poner un castigo
ejemplar y que estos hechos no vuelvan a
darse en la liga de fútbol mexicana